[Music]
there actually is nudity in the show and
oh yeah you seem like let's sound a
little pervy the way you said it sorry
you actually said oh yeah well it's a
fine line because you don't want people
to think that you're being creepy yes I
mean I've been told that many times okay
this is not something you would know
about but if you're turning up on set
every day and there are people who are
naked yes of both gender persuasions
mm-hmm with no clothes on you don't want
them to see you going yeah you don't
want that well that seems more angry
that didn't seem like you were turned on
it's felt like you were becoming a
caveman there's a way sort of troll like
yeah I know but you don't want people to
think that you you know Olga Ling them
or anything like that so it's actually I
did as a bit of research because my
character is starts off as a
gynecologist yes a sort of ob/gyn and so
I went to meet someone who works as a
gynecologist and I and I said you know
how does how does it work you if you're
a straight man and you're working with
women all day and they're naked and all
that and he said well you just switched
that part of your brain off you know you
just don't go then yeah and and I
thought well that's never gonna have I
don't understand that I get that as an
idea about right and then I turn up on
set and there are 15 naked women around
and if you let your mind go anywhere
near the kind of pervy area yes then you
would just die your head would explode
yeah the wonder of the handler something
would explode yeah yeah so
you don't want it you want it you want
it you can keep it control but you have
that that's a great dissent you just
have well I didn't even choose to do it
I just realized oh I've switched that
bit off I'm just not just not going
there I would like to think I could do
that I don't think I could I don't know
I think how do you think you would react
if you it would be very professional for
a little bit and then people would take
their robes off and I'd be like I would
start describing Isaac be king in tongue
exactly I think it would now there I'm a
cartoon character that's my problem
you we were talking in the dressing room
I tried to surprise you before the show
and you were actually I saw you half
that was partially clothed yes your part
you do that with all your guests I try
to yeah yeah I like to get there just
when I like to wait about five minutes
after they get to and then just push the
door open quickly and sometimes I have a
camera and what what Conan is not
mentioning is that this wasn't from the
outside coming you were already in the
bathroom of my dressing room yes and
just jumped up yeah five minutes I'm in
there sometimes for hours it's why the
show is clearly not rehearse
why don't we rehearse Conan's in the
bathroom waiting do you you were talking
about how you can be easily embarrassed
the and and and maybe feel a little bit
I don't know self-conscious is that a
problem for you when you bless job I
have a terrible set of competing
qualities one that I'm very easily
embarrassed and and two that I do
terribly embarrassing things those the
day you do yeah well I don't think they
are in the moment but they sort of tend
to be but so I have to be very careful
on the set yeah obviously I have to sort
of be careful I don't say the wrong
thing or look at a person in the wrong
area or you know just it's it's
difficult to to remember those sort of
things I mean I had to do one scene
where it was a scene where not to give
any spoilers but there's the scene where
someone tells me to disrobe take my
clothes off in the middle of a room
which I do and then they tell me too
difficult to know how to explain these
things but
the I think the polite form that we use
in the show is is Auto manipulation
which when's the Rockets what car is
involved yeah no you you're you're
pleasuring yourself yes although when I
say it with an American yeah it often
doesn't give me pleasure to be honest
but it can often be more like a like a
small battle with you here yeah like a
small skirmish yeah yeah well but
nevertheless I was gazetted that because
in the show I with American accent he's
an American character so when I say Auto
manipulation it sounds like Auto
manipulation yeah and someone did
actually think that I called my
appendage Auto manipulating autos
clearly German
[Applause]
you